In a previous video, you could see us getting
an old shipping container on our land.
So, we built a big roof on top to make it rainproof.
Added a storage system
on the outside for our material bank.
And, a waste system on the other side.
Now, we're going to finish it up in this last step,
to add storage inside and store our garden tools.
Welcome to a new Project Kamp update!
So, the container is here and it works great!
And, everything stays dry when it rains,
and the wood is stored properly.
The waste system functions!
But, one thing, the most exciting part
is actually the inside of the container.
Which we're going to do right now,
because it's currently messy...
So, yeah, here we store a bunch of things,
because it's our most dry storage place.
But, this also makes what we find in here very diverse.
We have like saws, screws for the workspace,
and an old desk chair that someone gave to us...
And, I actually don't know why it's not in the office.
This used to be 20 kilograms of cocoa powder,
and it's almost finished.
It's been a few years that we've been working on that.
Some tents, some racks from the refrigerator,
a water pump for fires, linseed oil to coat our wood...
Chainsaw oil, incomplete Precious Plastic dome,
and a happy birthday sign.
So, yeah, as you can see, a lot of random
objects with most of them useful.
But, we need to organize this so we can
properly access them and store them.
We're going to paint this side
and build a wall in the middle.
So, this is going to be the clean area.
Where we're going to store things,
like our food and long term storage, so it’s safe.
Over here is going to be more the day
to day tools.
And, the garden utilities we're all going to use,
so we can easily take them.
So, at the end, this should all be a super nice,
well equipped storage container.
Just like the outside, the inside is pretty rough as well,
like rusty areas welded.
And besides that, it's also just really dirty.
So, it could use a good clean up.
All right, so, first step:
take everything out and clean it up.
Time to get started!
The container is now empty!
I actually didn't do anything.
But next, we're gonna wash it.
Right now, I'm going to start taking out
some loose pieces of paint.
So, I'm going to start taking those out.
Rust isn't that big of a deal,
because the paint we're using can paint over rust easily.
So, yes, mainly just take all the loose paint out,
so that the paint sticks to the container.
The walls are now white, and it was a lot of work.
Jaime spent a lot of time brushing everything,
to make sure it's all nice and white.
It’s done!
So, next, we’re going to build the wall inside to close it up.
We have a lot of these panels from the yellow van I believe.
In the end, they didn't reuse them.
So, I'm going to reuse them now,
and make the part for the general help's workshop.
They need like a tool part for all the tools, all the saws and scissors.
I’m going to try to make it out of these.
Let’s see, if it can take the nails.
Yeah, I think it's strong enough!
So, I've been marking and drilling the holes to the board.
But, I drilled one of the holes into the wrong place,
so I have to make a plug there.
So, meanwhile, Eemeli is working on the front part.
I'm going to start here in the back,
to make the storage area.
And, the first thing we're going to do
is close out this wall.
So, it separates the area,
and so the mice cannot get in here anymore.
And, the tricky part is the bend in the container.
So, here the beam is touching,
and the beam is straight.
There is a big gap here.
So, we need to try to make the wall snug here,
so the mice cannot get through.
The wall is now in, and it got a little bit darker here.
But now, we're going to make the shelves inside.
The container has an extra edge here.
So, if you put the beam here, there's a gap.
So, we need to cut out a bit here..
All the shelves are now in, and it's getting pretty dark.
It must be really annoying for you guys as well.
But, luckily, the electronic parts arrived!
We're going to install the electricity!
So, we have some cable, a socket and switch, two big LED lights,
electrical boxes, cable connectors, some pipes...
And, tools.
We're going to install two lights,
two switches and a big socket here.
So, we can charge all the batteries.
We're going to hook it up to the solar system,
to make sure we get power supply.
Electricity comes out from the ground here.
We need to hook up the electricity to our main system.
Which is set up here, and it should be relatively easy,
because we already have a fuse box in place.
So, we’re just going to add it there,
and then continue to connect in the container.
We have a pretty long light,
and both of the connectors are at the end.
But unfortunately, the ceiling is a bit bumpy.
So, if we put this one here...
Without the connector, we cannot connect this one.
And the other way around,
because there a big bump here.
So, I need to find out a logical place for this light...
Testing time!
Now, we can see things!
So, now we just bought some off-the-shelf light switches.
Which works, but we like to have them
from Precious Plastic.
We already made sockets before,
but we would really like to have light switches as well.
We made a few before testing,
but it didn't really work.
And, then we stopped...
We got busy, so, for anyone that is able to make a mold...
To inject with a Precious Plastic machine,
you can get €1000.
For the first one, that shows us a working light switch.
So, we need a table in the container for the general help.
And, we made a fancy drawing,
so we can start building it.
And Robert is going to help me
with the metalworks.
Cutting stuff and also welding.
So, I can be doing other stuff...
- Sounds good.
Should come out fine, unless something goes wrong...
Chester is finally helping us.
Thank you!
- Do you like it?
Yes!
This is the tabletop.
It's quite nice, actually, but the surface is very rough, so...
Linseed oil
It's heavier than I remember!
- Look at them.
So happy!
Looks good!
Thank you.
So, I'm going to start welding the holders
for the brushcutters and the chainsaws.
I'm going to use these off-cuts from the table.
It's nice to use some offcuts,
since they're not going to waste.
Now, I got the things welded.
It sticks together.
I need to get something else,
to mount them to the container.
- Done?
Yeah, done!
- Cool!
Nice, Eemeli!
They look nice!
Can I touch it?
- No!
Okay...
- Did you finish Eemeli?
Yeah!
Now, all of the holders are painted,
so we can mount them to the wall.
- Cool!
Tools are here on the wall!
Pretty nice how it turned out actually!
- Are you speaking to yourself?
Yes, mostly...
So, this is the current mess that the general help uses.
There’s these crates where all of this stuff is.
Like, these helmets and the saws that are in the same one...
And, the clothes are more or less
in the same crates...
We also got some new tools, like these scissors.
Rope!
So, now we want to go through all of this stuff.
To figure out what goes to the wall,
and what goes to the boxes.
Nice glove!
So, this is what went in the crates:
Some brushcutter and chainsaw stuff.
Handles.
Blades.
Rope.
Gloves.
And, the harnesses.
Dave is working on the other side of the wall,
so I’m only allowed to show this side of the container.
- I'll be here listening.
Huh?
- I'll be here listening!
The only thing left for me is to mount the vice!
The vice is on the table, and the tools are on the wall.
Everything is ready!
And, there is still more space to add stuff.
Another helmet, another axe, or more pliers or something...
So, yeah, that's it for me!
For the last part, this is going to be a storage shelf for the kitchen.
We’re going to use this coated plywood.
The main reason for using this is that it's easy to clean.
Because, this side is going to be for the kitchen.
And, they might have experiments with
fermentation or some leaking jars.
So, in this way we can easily wipe it clean.
Not a big fan of using this material,
but we didn't really find another option that has big large panels.
So, if you have suggestions for that
for us in the future, let us know!
The design is pretty much based on a standard plywood size,
which you find here and then it's chopped in half.
So, that will be the width of this whole shelving system.
Which makes it easy to build,
but also easy to take apart later on.
Because, we didn't have to cut it that much.
Time to get started building!
Let’s make some space!
There is a big dent, which might be hard to see, but I see it...
The height of the shelf is based on
some storage items we have.
So, we have these ones,
which we already use in the kitchen right now.
But, we also have them in a bigger version.
Then, we have a jerrycan size, which is how
we get our vinegar and things like that.
A classic jar size, which will be one shelf
with exactly two on top.
So, we can reuse them to store things,
and preserve them for the long term.
All the wood has been cut and drilled!
Now, it's time for assembly!
This is the fun part.
Eemeli is going to help here.
- Yes!
Finnish precision.
So, there should be space here in the back...
Everything is now built!
We just need to clean it up,
and then let the teams fill up in the storage areas!
All right, so, the container is ready!
Let me show you the inside!
It's a bit tight in there...
So, we need a GoPro.
So, on this side, we have all the garden tools.
Hanging and organized by category of tools.
It's easy at the end of the day
to see what is missing.
So, we can either find it back on the land,
and make sure everything is in stock.
In here, we have our brush cutters.
We have two electric ones and one gas-powered,
so we can easily take them out.
Underneath, we have the chainsaws,
with an electric one and gas powered as well.
Then, on this side, we have all the smaller tools that we use.
So, we have some hammers, protective helmets, saws...
Well, you can see all the things.
Here, we can charge the batteries
for the chainsaw and the brush cutter.
We have a vice to put in a chainsaw,
so we can sharpen it.
So, we got some sharpening tools.
We have some organic rope,
so if you want to tie something quickly...
We get that, to put it on the land, and then just rots away.
So, no plastic rope.
Gloves, with right and the left one separated, since it’s easier.
And below, we have all the oils and gasoline.
For the chainsaw and the brush cutters,
to make sure they can run.
So, these are all the garden tools in here,
and sort of the landscape area.
And, over here...
We have this storage area.
So, on this side, the workspace.
Here, we have things like cutting disks...
Drills in stock...
And, drill bits.
The screws from our screw system...
Water filters, like a whole year supply of them.
To make sure we have clean drinking water.
We also store linseed oil and we have some paints here.
Some electrical components...
Yeah, it's not really fully equipped yet.
We can now start ordering all the things,
so until that time, it will be a bit empty.
We can also use it to store some future projects
that are coming up, like this one.
But, that’s the workspace area!
Then, over here we have the kitchen,
where we store things like bulk foods.
So, in these containers, for instance...
This one has rice.
If you're from Portugal, you know this guy: tremoços (= lupin beans).
Good snack!
We also use it to store preserved food here.
Over here, we have crates.
They all fit the standardized crate.
Some bottles to preserve the food.
Things like brushes and cloths to clean.
These are all new ones.
So, when they wear out or they break,
we can stock ourselves up with this.
Some potatoes.
And here, there is also a bit more kitchen things.
But, less food based, so baking soda for instance to clean
Our toilet paper, a big container of liquid soap,
to refill our hand soap.
So, we didn't have to buy the small packages all the time...
Washing powder.
And, that's kind of the main point of having this container,
so that we can buy things in bulk.
Because, buying things in bulk means
we can find a really good supplier.
We really put a lot of effort into that!
Less transport and less packaging!
And also, just less work, like less receipts,
less administration is just simplifying life.
And, up until now it was kind of hard to do,
because we didn't have the storage place.
But now, we can really bulk up, and make sure
we make better choices in the things we buy!
All right, so, now the container is fully renovated!
This is part of a three series video.
The first one, where we built the roof on top.
The second one, where we built the outside.
And now, the third one, where we built the inside.
You can find all the drawings online!
So, if you want replicate it or parts of it,
you can just download them.
And, next week, we're going to show you
probably the most risky thing we did so far at Project Kamp...
It doesn't have to do anything
with construction or renovation or tools.
If you're already going to see that video,
make sure to support us on Patreon!
So, you can see the video right now!
One week ahead and also without advertisement!
Or not, and just subscribe
and see the video next week.
Thanks for watching, and see you in the next update!